well the good day team we have covered
the rising prices of gas and groceries
over the past couple of weeks and we
certainly know that it impacts all of
you all of our viewers so we've started
a campaign in cooperation with smith to
help gift you a good day let's take a
look at how i surprised one local lucky
smith shopper and gifted her a good day
hey everybody okay so i'm outside of
smith and eight news now and smith's are
about to give someone a good day and
it's a surprise follow me
met denise at smith's on west warm
springs she thought we were interviewing
her about an increase in grocery store
prices it's hard on the family budget
during our interview we learned denise
has had a lot on her plate recently lost
my husband and now i'm taking care of my
brother then she got an unexpected gift
smiths and eight news now would like to
gift you a good day
and pay for your groceries today believe
it
oh my goodness thank you so much i
cannot believe it you guys are awesome
today is it's for my brother and today's
his birthday
so this is unbelievable i cannot believe
it
it's a perfect present then to share
with him as well yes even though i've
lost my soul mate i still have a good
family and a great community
we're very lucky
she is an incredible community member it
was really just a pleasure meeting her
and gifting her with this surprise
ah and you never know you could be next
keep an eye out for the good day team
watch good day at the same time on
monday we're going to gift someone else
a good day